yes man schön da habe ich jetzt auch
noch ein spaß bekommt
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker show das ist
ein format in dem ich material von
minecraft hacker das e mail zu schicken
mir anschaue und das kommentiere für
euch sucht also die witzigsten
lustigsten hacker aus den einsendungen
heraus und zeigt ihr euch hier im wege
selbst war in einer folge erscheinen
wollt dann könnt ihr mir material zu
schicken
das geht so dass ihr das video material
auf youtube hochladen als ungelöstes
video den link zu diesem um gelisteten
video entweder per mail an hacker
shootout druck.de schick oder als
private youtube nachricht so weit so gut
leute dann lass uns mal loslegen die
erste 1 sendung stammt von lord
replacing und sie heißt hacker shop.de
dreister geht's sich jump league hacker
ftw okay man über lord wie schau mal
rein was für fünf fast soweit alles ganz
gut aus ist ja okay dafür ganz normale
leute verteilen sich die kassen
composite war jetzt total fläche den
hacker gespottet also schon tot war
dieser typ mit den dia woods vielen ja
okay okay im moment könnt ihr diesen
moment wenn leute sich einfach denken
okay da ist der wand ich könnte einfach
ein block nach rechts gehen an der wand
vorbei gehen aber hey ich habs spyder
heck und ich laufe einfach die wand hoch
wie dumm das ist einfach so unnötig hat
ihn vor allem nicht mal schneller
gemacht um ihr könnt einfach hier rum
außen vorbei laufen stattdessen alles
klar
ok damit steht aber fest wir haben auf
jeden fall ein hacker was wo sind die
jetzt in the [ __ ] okay da hinten sehen
dass er da ist es besser er was das für
eine kamera facebook als ort eva kalter
sommer wär hätte in dieser runde
eigentlich nicht dass beide hat einfach
mal die wand hoch
meine oma hat immer dazu gesagt als
beide an der bonewitz ja wollen jetzt
fehlt einfach ein bisschen an der wand
okay jetzt läuft ihm hinterher pass mal
auf mal gucken was er als martin wasser
noch verhext hat weiß gar nicht wer in
dieser runde hat und wer nicht mehr
hektisch zu ordern also fall der mit den
dire boots ist einer von den hacker du
schaust du jetzt richtig
okay das hat er gar wahrscheinlich
internetbrowser aufgemacht jetzt geht's
wieder geschlossen
besser kommt ok team ist aber erlaubt
ihm ist erlaubt
die hitze auch recht seltsam aus wie
geil das ist halt wirklich hacker wird
es hacker der eine den anderen an
aber okay also diesen spyder hektar aber
hey wie random ist das also erstmal das
einfach beide hätten so und er an dieser
aktion ist es immer noch sagenhafte
hätte einfach raus herumlaufen können
okay aber wollten zeigen dass effekt
dann passiert mir die spucke camera
action unter da sieht man es da sieht
man's er mich hier sieht man es auch
hier führt dieser gelbe einfach mal
fliegt nicht aber klettert die wand hoch
alles klar
sodann ganz groß auf diesem moment wie
der gelbe jetzt einfach der goldene
jetzt den typen etwa zwei hektar auf
sagt sagt sagt sagt zack zack
ok vor der zweiten sendung eine kurze
geschichte ich mache ja momentan in
berlin bei dessen praktikums holen
darüber habe ich die jungs von kipo
kennengelernt und die haben mich gefragt
ob ich nicht mal deren idee in einem
video vorstellen möchte und weil ich
sowohl jungs als auch die idee selbst
ganz gut finde hier in der kurze
erklärung also stelle ich mal drei
personen vor eine person bisschen
vermittler eine person aus dem käufer
eines ein verkäufer wenn der vermittler
einkäufer an einen verkäufer vermittelt
und der verkäufer dann dadurch umsatz
macht kriegt dieser vermittler oftmals
provision und was kino macht was jungs
von kipo machen ist dass sie in teil
dieser provisionen die sie endlich
bekommen würden einfach an den käufer
zurückgeben und so kann der käufer dann
wenn er was kauft direkt geld
zurückbekommen cashback nennt sich das
das machen die für die verschiedensten
sachen für klamotten für spielzeuge aber
auch für games und für pizza was richtig
geiles ich habe euch denn website und
die aktion gerade und mal in der
beschreibung von links wenn jetzt
irgendwie games kaufen wollt demnächst
keine ahnung fifa 31 oder eine pizza und
dabei halt dieses cashback nutzen wollt
also geld aber ersparen wollt dann könnt
ihr auf der linken der beschreibung
klicken und dann könnt ihr euch die
ganze geschichte anschauen aber jetzt
zur zweiten einsendung die stammt von
defi sprich das richtig aus und sie
heißt hier sitzt hier lustiger bedrooms
hacker
momentan zwar das wasser wieder gesehen
hatte mal kurz da rechts drauf habe ich
in der etwas eingebildet oder diese
person sollte eigentlich nicht da sein
oder weil da ist nicht ausgeprägt ist
sondern packe ich schon mal weiter okay
da unten da zeigt jetzt der verein
soldaten als ob das will ich sehen dass
ich den fluch in herten
okay okay okay hier sind welche ja alles
klar
lila verfolgt gelb reden halt im
hintergrund deswegen auch die anwendung
da aber habt ihr euren text aber wo ist
jetzt diese angebliche fly hecke der
stadt potenza
oh ja das sieht man nicht solide tauss
ok ok auf jeden fall dass es auf jeden
fall hacker ja kann man kurz mal den
originalton machen
aber bisher ist noch nicht geflogen ist
noch nicht geflogen ist wirklich frei
hacker oder baut er sich einfach schnell
okay sagt ag ja die hitze auch bisschen
komisch aus komitee papa papa komm schon
komplett kostenlos schlägt einfach die
spieler darum in der luft ist kühl oder
steckten in die luft ragen ich muss
einfach wieder reagieren das sagen alle
ja alles gut
er ist noch nicht geflogen und jetzt
passt jetzt auch wenn die überfliegt die
sagen die sagen die jungs schon handy
schlägt aber so in die luft man die
sinnlos
schön da habe ich jetzt auch noch mal
sprach so kommen wie ich warte einfach
die ganze zeit darauf dass diese typen
loslegt ist wieder dort fünf minuten und
jetzt ja es ist immer noch ein hacker
und man sollte nicht hacken aber das
wird sich für dich das echt wird sich
wohl jetzt steckt er einfach der wand
okay leute die letzte einstellung des
heutigen tage stammt von arrow vor und
er schreibt das nimmt die spieler report
und wir gucken mal ein ja gut dass er
schon mal sehr komisch aus alles klar
natürlich alles klar kommt wie
selbstverständlich er darüber läuft in
diesem moment wenn wasser vor ihr
bassist und die kija kommentar
es stimmt also weg aber jetzt kommt
nicht durch guck mal hier musste jetzt
hier irgendwie die hacks ausmachen durch
die wand da durchzukommen ist sogar
wieder etwas und man immer wieder
einfach so richtig langweilt übers
wasser drüber läuft ja wohl richtig
frech richtig frech man läuft über den
strand noch einmal wasser ich habe die
jesus hacks kann ich für mich wenn dann
da haben wir dann im wasser ist so
bitter wenn man im wasser da ist man
kann nicht wegschwimmen und der andere
läuft einfach über das wasser auf einen
zu unrecht ein werk so das was auch so
weit von der heutigen folge hacker schon
wendig gefangen etwas gerne daumen nach
oben da oder ein abo für weitere folgen
die schau gibt es jeden sonntag auf
einem kanal eine sache noch schickt die
einsendung am besten nur ein hacker
stoffe.de weil youtube pn
irgendwie nicht so läuft schon jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht so an
um ehrlich zu sein also am besten alles
an hacker shoutout blog.de und ihr könnt
ruhig einsenden wenn wir für die
nächsten folgen wieder ein bisschen
material das war's mir danke fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns wieder haut rein
macht es gut und ciao